ladies Congrats on the film thank you I
have to say how do you go into the ocean
again after doing this film you don't ya
ever don't ever do it again do you have
a different feeling of sharks now where
you like maybe a fan before and now
you're like a cousin who like sharks but
he's like one of those people who like
likes animals has he gone into a cage
with distance yeah they're really like
fascinating creatures obviously like but
I don't want to encounter one now
obviously this is the two of you your
first film but it's your kind of
pathetic escape I mean what was it like
being a vet versus being nucleus I mean
they did not seem like nice to me like
if I was they were they did it so well
from there they wanted there were total
troopers cysteine which is like jumping
on every occasions like I'm gonna do all
my stuff so it was just amazing and and
we all had each other's backs and we
were all complete equals we were treated
exactly the same because we were all
going to the same situation and
obviously I had done like a little more
acting but I mean I was new to this
underwater world as well so we were all
faced with the same fear in the same
struggle yes yeah and how's it been
being your first major like film roles I
think this was like an amazing first
role because there was so many
challenges beyond just acting you know
we had to learn how to swim and you know
learn how to dive and so we were all
kind of going through this together so
we didn't really feel like she was
saying they're not like equals you know
that's nice no I do have to mention
obviously your dad sir you know very
well known shocking I thought what what
do they think about you guys doing a
film together Oh what do you think he
doesn't know you're in it I think I
think on the red carpet we'll reunite
and they'll be like oh yeah I've done a
movie together yeah they did one in 2003
yes but
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] need actually saw
the trailer for like it's affecting this
question well yeah I think you should
make that happen make it a moment on the
carpet be like yeah my dad your dad like
really spot-on
I mean I think everyone everyone that's
might know but that'd be great yeah okay
last add question I promise but who do
you think would you want to take with
you to fight awesome sharks I heard yeah
no he's useless winner
he's such about somewhere that's
definitely where I got it from no I saw
you guys probably better know it could
be worse than slide I mean if he's a
good swimmer or something I should do
yeah
[Laughter]
now obviously a lot of this film takes
place underwater what was that like
filming all of those scenes it was
exhausting
like physically and emotionally
demanding there were just little things
that I don't think we had expected even
just even spending the amount of time
underwater II like your skin would get
soft and then every time you'd bump into
something you'd get like a guy literally
cars and like I think doing it with them
was really good I don't think I could
have done it by myself or even with one
other girl cuz they were so supportive
so we'd always just give me each other
this look like okay yeah you're hurting
too okay now and you all got certified
as Lexus yeah yeah our hoodies written
like diverse services well I would
understand and you filmed the underwater
stuff primarily at Pinewood crack yes we
films in London
finally cool did y'all try to like peek
over at Star Wars really they did they
were star
but they had like it all blocked off see
anything we tried though yeah I respect
that I respect that now were you fans of
the first film yeah sure I saw like
randomly on Netflix with my sister and
loved it loved how this new aspect of it
being underwater and they're talking
underwater was like I had no idea how
they did it and then a week later the
director called me and wanted me to
audition I was like oh my god yes I
didn't want to do it yeah so yeah I feel
like a lot of people you know it's not
something that you know you would think
oh man but it's terrifying and there's a
reason there's not a lot of movies
filmed underwater yeah